welcome to our short course in economics
where we learn how we make choices when
unlimited human wants meet limited
resources
supply and demand shows how people
coordinate their decisions by
communicating through prices supply
refers to the number of goods and
services that sellers produce at a
certain price
demand refers to how many goods and
services consumers are willing to buy at
a certain price
let's assume there is just one coffee
shop on the market but a hundred people
who drink coffee the price of coffee is
three dollars per cup and the people
each drink one cup per day
we can illustrate this with a diagram
showing the price per cup of coffee on
the vertical axis and the number of cups
of coffee consumed on the horizontal
axis
at three dollars 100 cups are demanded
what do you think how many cups of
coffee would these 100 people drink if
the price of a cup were to increase to
eight dollars
while at three dollars a hundred people
drink a cup of coffee at eight dollars
maybe just 30 do and at 12
there could be as few as 10 people
interested in purchasing a cup however
at a dollar per cup demand could go up
to 150 cups a day because some of those
original 100 customers are now drinking
two or more cups
this is what economists call a demand
curve it shows how much quantity is in
demand at each price
the curve usually slopes downwards
because economists assume that the lower
the price the higher the quantity
demanded
the supply curve shows the number of
goods or services sellers are willing to
provide at a given price it curves
upward because the higher the price the
more supply
[Music]
as we already know at one dollar the
people on the market demand 150 cups a
day however the owner already pays 1.20
for the beans per cup which means he
can't sell a cup for just one dollar
if the price were to be 12 per cup the
owner could hire two additional staff
while supplying up to 150 cups
unfortunately only 10 customers would
buy at this price and that's not enough
to cover the cost of business
the sweet spot happens to be at three
dollars at this cost the owner can hire
one employee and happily supply the 100
cups a day that are demanded at that
price
supply and demand on one graph look like
this
at 12
the owner can supply 150 cups but only
10 people would buy a cup of coffee at
that price
at one dollar he can't supply any but
demand would be 150 cups of coffee
the two curves meet at 3 and 100 cups
let's now assume circumstances change
the summer was very hot and there was
only a little rain which left many
coffee bean crops destroyed
the poor harvest yielded a low supply of
beans as a result more traders bid for
the limited amount of beans leading to
an increase in the price
[Music]
the shop owner now buys the beans from
the farmer at two dollars for the beans
per cup
can he still sell at three dollars he
tries and decides to let go of his
employee and begins serving coffee all
by himself
but he cannot meet the demand of all his
customers if the government were to
force him to keep the price fixed
through so-called price controls queuing
would be part of everyone's life
to reduce the wait times for his clients
and make up for the increased cost of
the beans the owner decides to increase
the price of the coffee to four dollars
and fifty cents
the supply curve now shifts to the left
and at four dollars and fifty cents the
shop will sell 70 cups of coffee per day
typically the higher the selling price
of a good the greater number of people
willing to supply it this means that
there will likely be more competition
soon
[Music]
in real life and within a free market if
you drink coffee at four dollars and
fifty cents it's not the basis of an
economic calculation but the result of
an endless dance of trial and error
between sellers and buyers that lead
them to reach an unspoken agreement
about what works best for both this
phenomenon is referred to as emergent
order
before we summarize please note that
economists differentiate between
quantity demanded and demand
a change in the quantity demanded
happens due to a change in price like we
explored when the price dropped and the
quantity demanded increased
a change in demand happens when the
environment changes let's imagine that
many people in the market become more
health conscious and think that coffee
is bad if that happens the entire demand
curve shifts downward and at three
dollars not a hundred buy coffee but
just 40.
let's summarize supply is the amount
provided at each price demand is the
amount purchased at each price the final
price is the result of an emergent order
if you are up for it we will now ask you
to help us understand today's price of
coffee post your thoughts in the
comments below
search for a coffee price chart and
you'll find a graph showing the price of
coffee in u.s dollars then tell us
what's the price of one kilogram of
coffee today what do you think are the
reasons that have caused the price to
fluctuate in the past five years
[Music]
this and all other sprouts videos are
licensed under creative commons that
means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms online
courses or to start projects and today
thousands already do
to learn how it works and download this
video without ads or background music
check out our website or read the
description below
if you want to support our mission and
help change education visit our patreon
that's patreon.com
sprouts